welcome to cloud minute today I'm going  to show you how to enable and disable  api's on Google cloud platform if you  are trying to use a GCP product but are  receiving an unauthorized error you  should double check that the API is  enabled on GCP you have to enable the  API that you want your project to use  from Google Cloud console click API  manager and then enable API you can  search for the API you need to enable  I'm enabling the cloud natural language  API  on the details page you can see more  information about the API access the  documentation or enable or disable the  API once it is enabled I can use the API  from my code I can also see information  about my usage and any errors I've  received on this page if you want to see  all the api's in use on your project  click on the dashboard if you need to  disable any of these api's you can do  that from here that's it